sweepy Doug pictures probably cuz I
haven't played a game you guys in a very
long time
one second our game oh my god okay wait
hi guys it has been a long time since I
have sat down and recorded a gameplay
for you usually I do live streams I try
to just live stream this way Internet
it's not a thing
just not happening snarf thing so I'm
playing it now for you and then you will
see it in the future we're doing this
old school this is man of Madden not
sure if you have heard of it before but
it's by supermassive games the people
who made until adorned and that game was
great I loved how they got film concepts
of like typical horror films so you had
two tropes of kind of romantic couples
and ditzy girls and the jock guys they
had all them in there and it was just
really cool it's one of those games
where you get to choose what kind of
happens it's one of those games that
also is merging blurring the lines
between film and gaming and if you know
me you know that I love a bit of both so
any game that wants to blur those lines
I'm I'm all for it I'm going to be there
and I love horror so without further ado
let's see how mad have Mendozas I'm
gonna play alone I have new friends so
I'm gonna play alone I guess
can I just do the backtrack
[Music]
[Music]
it was like my home my yuppie mine
rights were on a ship
with the army the American army and
those were people who died at the war I
suppose
nice lanterns
[Music]
Cheers all righty buster
we better mosey on back to the ship I
think she's a little bit stop the
presses
what looks like Oh charlie Charming's
got a little business to attend to me no
more DOMA oh sure
can I fight hey give me a quarter
why I'm gonna find out my future
let's have it what's in store for me pop
III change here play yours even MA
do you be so wait no I didn't mean to
what am I gonna hit the jackpot
no all that glitz and glamour and then
it means choose that I know I chose the
[ __ ] option
I'm a geeky I was just trying to figure
out which which one to use bamboo title
a dragon tail bamboo I'll be a koala
koala bear punch a jump
hold our tea
yeah this looks like a fish
neither stifle your fortune corn unlike
the food come from any distraction
direction direction like a mysterious
wind we lie but when a winds like this
neighbor that oh yeah can do much more
maturely
that doesn't really sound like a very
good Wells doom
wait what what's that mean Janani what's
that mean what the hell man you wouldn't
want to ask the dickish question let me
get it go at it oh yeah
thing you got the stuff you know be
neither polio daughter go home I sure
fine sure
she's such a poster what do we have
today
I'll give it a whirl oh it well
no some such a Lud look at me go wait my
fists of fury no I'm using a ps4
controller I didn't think this through
and it's oh no where's the axon next
Watson Troy because I'm failing this on
PC but I'm using ps4 controller and it's
telling me to do Xbox things and I'm now
very confused you in each one equal I
can't fight wait this one no this way oh
what's Fiona Xbox I missed it I mean I
were have a nice day
ok I'm gonna suck at this you wanna see
some sweetness finally you keep watchin
come on man just let me ask you another
question
what's my trades reckless insecure
selfish and altruistic oh my gosh I'm an
actual douchebag
[Music]
baby
[Music]
okay so
where do they get that from and what is
in what's in the box
and
50 says
come on
[Music]
it's noise actually making it
why I'm comfortable
men appear to be drunk off there
[Music]
to the medical
in the fridge and tooth
[Music]
okay this is interesting
it doesn't seem as generic of plots as
well
[Music]
some sort of substance
find its ways about the whole ship now
[Music]
who's that
- pops come back soon oh is that his
his son
kind of cute
okay I was not expecting that
on a key
sure
to know what it's for maybe the door
take his pen you can never have too many
pens right
okay so all we know is that these are
some sort of like Marines our army
people there was some weird smoke on
that Charlie on the shadow table off
just get me out of here
oh look it's on me okay
heard aircraft and gunfire gun tamiya
and there was a glass them in the
sickbay something's wrong
let's get out of here
wait should we have a little it in a
room was there anything in there
here
in that private Charles Anderson on
leave from dirty did display
intoxication in a manner not becoming of
a member of the US Army private Anderson
was engaging with a number soldier in a
drunken argument it is the opinion of
the arresting officer that this would
lead to a public brawl and steps were
taken to ensure that both men were to
return to their ship or aren't aren't
you very thought
Arthur Miller petty theft one day Briggs
small items belong
locker items recovered miteta owner
brick found drunk announcing effort
so this is everyone that was put in this
room for different reasons I suppose all
right well we have a little key can we
open this safe we're thinking
don't be like look at our items let me
happen me let me just see how selfish we
are oh he's also insecure
come on then
damn we go
- sorry jokes dead
[Music]
where's the heartbeat
here I said a is X oh this is cool
[Music]
never remembered and she tonight would
they may be that gas is turn them into
something that we can't trust anymore Oh
this is actually quite a cool mechanic
oof
if you escape
the controls are a little bit of awkward
I'm not gonna lie it's gonna be our son
isn't it it's gonna look like some but
it's not our son it's gonna be like some
crazy demon or something
the ship why is he looking into a locker
looking at crazy fool
tell me can I look can I look at what
you're looking at I want to look at what
you're looking at where you got man
fine whatever we'll just carry he's just
getting out of our way so we have to go
first as me yeah
he's like nope so the little kid he's
like no can we run
hey Charlie hell
[ __ ] yeah you said it
fubar in that song
but
what about following with that little
kid when
I'm going dead another step Oh Danny
Buckley last time I saw him in the mess
hall he was fit as a fiddle poor [ __ ]
yeah it's
not anymore
this reminds me of Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets you know like when
people see that snake they freeze up we
need to find him never uh-oh the steam
that's not a good sign is it this is a
cool camera angle Oh
oh thank you for finally letting me own
not this one
but finally letting me know that what's
down here
right so those are great journey and
pretty glad I went down is it just me or
are you getting a real strange feeling
right now look like a guy he looks like
Sardar each other
wait it doesn't mean depressed it's like
it's his kid is the kid that was next to
his bed is alright
okay so is it just us two didn't see him
or did our friend just miss that creepy
kid Charlie
get over here
it's interesting because not all of them
are dead from gunshot wow this at least
we've got I see guns now I feel so much
safer y'all that's not the way they
spent on that exam
we need to make some more choices to
give us some nicer personality
attributes
[Music]
oh god no charlie
I mean why are you playing no no no no
no no I don't want to I don't want to
hurt kids I'm not doing it i refresh
[Music]
I might actually die
later
is anyone there hello can anyone up
there hear me this is the end
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay well
[Music]
I
do I win a prize for quickest death
because I think I should
[Music]
whoa hey what is happening with this
okay so I'm going to talk over this part
I'm guessing what just happened was we
played a scenario that where we would
have died either way
shooting the kid saving the kid won't
save it again not shooting the kid being
a coward and now the real game starts
and where a to check who looks into past
cases of mysteries and tries to figure
out what happened I'm not saying that
it's the truth I'm just saying that's
what I'm seeing and that's what I am NOT
shooting is happening because the game
has carried on even though I died and I
thought I had died crazy quickly but
apparently not my report
okay so this is a bit more like until
dawn
I am the curator the curator of stories
stories of love and hate greed and
beauty life and death stories such as
this one okay I was wrong he's not
exactly called the stories you choose to
tell you see this tale is only part
written and the choices you make will
complete it and determine whether the
lives of those with whom you are
interfering continue to flourish or
whether they are snuffed out you see we
each make decisions according to our own
moral compass and we have to live with
those decisions or die by them but you
shouldn't fear death it is after all
inevitable it is the tax one pays for
having lived and it comes eventually to
everybody still none of us want for it
to come too soon do as in life the
actions you take matter the choices you
make will affect others I'll be keeping
a close eye on your progress it's not my
place to interfere but I might be
persuaded to offer the occasional hint
here's one for free there are pictures
in this world that can show you some
possible futures if you can find them
and study them they may just help you to
make better decisions
or should I say decisions that result in
the outcomes you would prefer that's all
for the moment we'll talk again soon
enough we'll have the opportunity to
account for all the actions that you've
taken
whatever mess you've made I think I made
a mess to be honest I
[Music]
but yeah I am preferring this thought
the beginning kind of confuse me it
seemed very different until dawn
I'm intrigued as to how it's gonna tie
in
we'll find out witty Brad Alex's brother
Anderson's
you guys face it right bride's father
Julian's boyfriend and secure you gotta
know if we went out we can always call
for backup so uh look I've never been
down there before down the water diving
and maybe you could show me how the pros
do it are you serious yeah I mean are
you serious you came out here without
taking any lessons kind of yeah
nothing that's fun well anyway let's get
this all loaded up yeah well careful
mother that dive cam is like super
accessible be cool what Julian Conrad
are you know how do I say super [ __ ]
loaded so don't sweat the little stuff
man it's not cool
don't make me regret letting you tag
along why is this douche huh take along
seriously I thought it was invited Julia
wanted you to come along for real Julia
yeah man she wanted you to come
I wanted her to see how cool you are
which you're not so be cool
capisce all right let me go Calvary's
almost here whoo sorry I'm a little
snappy I'm just okay yeah now is best
for you no total shocker and man the
long-distance thing
Julia it's been rough yeah yeah I got
you it must be tough
don't worry me see I'm a nice brother
yep
all right I like you what Conrad doesn't
think we have enough beer ah because I
keep these in an undisclosed location
yeah
Hey so what can I get your input on
something yeah what just another big
thing I'm trying to make a decision
about about finishing med school no but
it's just kind of a big life choice you
know I don't know what's the right thing
to do
hmm get some thought you sure you're
ready give it some thought consider all
the permutations that's what I do
overthink absolutely everything hey
Julia she's the one that I'm writing uh
she's reckless yeah
and Conrad foolhardy and relaxed I know
his face can't think where oh sorry
Connie this is Alex hey what's up man
dude watch is this Ladykiller right here
so where we see act ISM game it's not a
pilot meet your kyrat it's Brad by the
way a little bro hey Bradley feel like I
already know you have heard so much
about you yeah likewise
amen want to crack the colon with me
every second
and the next I'm cool I'm cool that's my
relationship Oh
right on radical I like to cut your she
radical it's Jim
you ever do any diving before
[Music]
never no actually never done it before
water virgin nights hey you pop your
cherry together where's the old crest
bucket skippering
bless captain of Duke of Milan yeah
courageous my patient
I'd invite you to make yourselves at
home but looks like you already have
so is everybody on board and ready to go
okay
[Music]
[Music]
just a little dickish I like it
[Music]
oh that's it get it all out oh yeah see
she's mine okay you uh want to go lie
down
yeah you know maybe I should yeah
little boy
what about over here that's pretty far
out of the way I'm just thinking about
backup targets in case we don't find
anything on the dive cam listen to be
honest I've never heard of this rekt
you're looking for usually these things
are crawling with divers yeah this is
different I'm just saying if it gets too
late I know some nice places where you
can just take you know a nice dive um
bad guys did his homework if he says the
wrecks here it's here okay look you're
the client I'm just saying we don't have
unlimited daylight I'm gonna go help
Conrad to Julie with the camera oh so
she's not actually a friend she's just
owns the boat I guess
feast your eyes on this
brats calculations were right on the
money Oh kids a whiz we should thank him
what we found a plane yeah that looks
like world war two we are ready to dive
technically we should call this into
port authorities as an unreported direct
well technically are you sure you don't
want to do this the right way yeah I see
nothing
guys no one knows no one cares nobody
old man the right way come on what is
this kindergarten I had to bring it up
if we just go down and take a look who's
gonna know fine as long as you're quick
don't touch anything I just can't wait
to be the first one down there can you
imagine I'm touched
don't touch anything we should be ready
to get you guys in the water and a few
I'll set up the tanks the boys will do
the final checks take a look at the
camera see if you can find anything
useful right oh hey maybe you should
check on your bro that was a ready
camera cut
okay where is almost got the year good
to go
needing extra hand never use a
rebreather before I think we're in good
shape it's probably not a bad idea for
you to have a clue how these things work
gotta say not too happy with our captain
at the moment why she's just being
[Music]
seriously where does she get off
bitching about it oh wait wait wait and
didn't mean that fortune on the street
rules are rules
I get it but what's the big deal if
nobody finds out yeah that's what I'm
saying
she says rebreathers up and then we'll
go through the final steps together that
means just as many row decisions let's
talk to you captain
you know we have rules out here for a
reason you guys got to respect that
yeah he's so two-faced now everybody's
just a little we've been planning this
whole thing for a while now I get it but
there are rules and laws and customs
these rules are all pretty basic stuff
how much experience do out with these
kind of dives that a couple wrecks over
the years
I'm expert but you know experience if
this is your first unreported wreck then
you should know there's a very specific
protocol you have to follow for all you
know this could be a war grave
disturbing it would be illegal and
immoral okay so they're gonna find the
shipwreck no no no compass I get it
I just thought I'd get it how much way
how much money will it take for you to
stop breathing down our necks you this
is not about the money you know what I
can't stop you just respect the rules
down there don't do anything stupid
that'll get my ass in trouble see she
could just turn around now sir she is
actually pretty cool
why did I just turn it off you know how
to use that no not really you take my
way I just let it do its thing
sorry it's turn it back on
nevermind wilco dumpster
what's up
they do it sorry that brewski got the
better of me
hey all part of the adventure sorry for
putting a damper on things
stories dude you're more than that just
a script trip let's get some rest
come back when you're feeling better
okay at least I'm a nice brother if I'm
not a nice person I'm not sure Julia
left anything on the mainland
why am i sniffing as well as good's a
cost this made her happy
okay cool why my snooping see my
girlfriend stuff
Premonition our lungs that's what could
happen in the future
hey guys thanks already thanks a lot
so that's how I Dean wait it was an
expired visa
stuffers
that's a chunky weird tablet
but Nautilus
they're just me or did did you guys see
something there don't know what that is
I think it's just a boy
Baban on the water okay we ready we go
in okay so this is the rebreather way
cooler than a regular scuba setup it
takes all that co2 that you'd normally
just exhale into the water and instead
it gets totally reused then it reduces
decompression time on your way up
stay vide art okay Oh to check done oh
you gotta check your o2 first thanks for
setting me straight oh hey guys what
Jesus why are you so loud I almost
completely forgot when I was looking at
the dive cam I saw this huge hole in
tail kibou that's your way into the
plane oh nice work man thanks fun right
no touching okay you little clown fishes
see what you miss is that - you behave
Connie I'll be a see the camera you're
on camera I'll take the wheel it's get a
before photo
maybe we can fire it up again tonight
for our private post a special are you
gonna bring your bang stick that front
cab and it's gonna pop up anything
that's sick right have I just missed the
opportunity to take the stick oh this
might be bad all I have with me as a
gamma shaped I just missed that
opportunity to flirt with my girl oh
well I think she feels loved
oh yes more or less
since it just sent it
she listened so tight she had someone
arrives on the plane
hey sudeer would be cool it's not like
one tiny little thing would hurt anybody
she acts like we're gonna run suck the
plane only be good scale the work told
us about running the plane yeah thank
you
that's gotta be like way bigger
it's pretty intact - this is a [ __ ]
remarkable find let's move around a
little and find a way
I'll see it was a boy and see it boban
howdy captain you fancy a pint with your
second-in-command
you are not my second-in-command third
and a minute
no she's direction here cabin I still I
know you're well paying dashingly
handsome seafaring client
it's requesting the pleasure of your
company over a frosty amber liquid I
need to focus
Pass no jaw stay focused on your friends
down there
pretty nice ride you got here
where'd you get the cash ah
South Shore you know it's not polite to
ask a lady about her money fair enough
yeah I was just thinking about buying a
boat myself and I thought maybe you'd
like to point me in the right direction
sure whatever you know but I think you
were a pleasure to help you parked with
your money you know what I better spend
some time keeping the Duke of Milan do
my time that thing okay
let's go check on the nice brother
see how he's dead how's it going knocked
out by cold frosty man I feel like such
a wimp is that right hey it's your
vacation you're a lot to overdo it he's
turning a temperance Club party of one
lifetime membership hope the lovebirds
are having the time of their lives down
there I hope they know what they're
doing down there
attitude matters twenty meters down Alex
place the goof but he was pretty serious
about acing his diving certification are
you close with your brothers don't in my
whole life
Julia's got Alex wrapped around her
little finger huh
gotta get back up top check you later
can I add from the stone I can open this
door the toilet and what is it
why do I keep these around
this letter is in an informal L it's a
formal notification that you are in
default of your obligation to make
certain payments also she can actually
afford the boat smarts been overdue
since this date compared to the old
mantra press unless the out signing
amount
mmm is received I have no choice but to
begin the foreclosure process
no okay so this is why she's allowing
them to do that because she needs the
money
Duke - Alex Duke - Julia
can be here under the water I guess they
have an endo in their suits
I thought she was just gonna die then
okay I'm coming down what if I use this
wait never talk to this guy talk talk
okay there how's it hanging she says oh
good as I am you look like you're taking
full advantage of here
what's that about that is not the Coast
Guard so we're not under arrest
how should we handle this sorry she's a
badass she's not doing anything I'm the
captain so you'd be quiet and let me
handle it
you got that
guys you gotta keep back we've got
divers in the water
[Music]
hey we got damage here you see this look
at home we can take care of this man
it's not a problem what do you think
like 10 bucks cover it is he just
chuckling - my bad let's make it 20 well
shoot you you think it's more like 30 I
can do 30 it's nobody gonna use the
holster that drive our bargain but I'm
with you here I just thrown the whole
pot
money does not solve everything
they're kind of be typing like oh this
money is just falling from the surface
Conrad said one of the pictures on an
opening
but turn you can get in through there
oh I didn't realize he dangerous
oh yeah I know now ladies first
I wasn't paying attention
can I just take a second to say holy
[ __ ] I like so we did it I mean can you
believe it
Oh what was that she was holding that
she's
how look a panic attack or something
like that
get up
Julia leaves it you're not gonna take
your gear off to get in they're not
worth it
that is pretty tight what are you
getting stuff without your ring breeder
yeah please don't do it maybe it is kind
of dangerous
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna go ahead I don't
know I can tell that what am i doing
why do you stop her
Octopussy
cool
oh god how could she hold her breasts
about huh
[ __ ] a duck in the ass got it got it
oh gosh Lisa I go right now you did
something stupid down here that's it
what chance you get back okay yeah now
say madly
it's glad you're okay don't do it again
please gonna give me a heart attack
same did I got this Oh what was that was
not what I said it was a rescue call
launched from a US base Kowalski
way to help out of shape Oh ash ship hey
wow it's pushing the narrative lo mismo
bullet holes along the fuselage
that's gonna flip when it sees this
you're gonna take its own but like look
we could have been looking Billy
[Music]
good God
that's what you can
coop Seminoles
I'll be ready doing this oh he's holding
something ah cute
some lady
something something whatever ties
Wow
what the hell happened here it'll look
things they knew they were goners Jesus
Roger it's all fun yeah I know it is
which is we just found this
you hear that let's check it out
want to go first
this what's X oh I've read like a pop oh
damn it
this is confusing easy my pop is broken
oh it's okay I beg strong man I can do
it for us only they've got gun
what do video
pilot and co-pilot gotta be
plane crash not high on my list waste
perish
but they have a guns or something and
there was bullet holes
now okay up again Oh
it's a great week shark not interested
in us let's go
luckily for you
on us not I
what are you doing why are you fidgeting
wait she's gonna ask her I don't know
why I wanted to bring something up with
you but it's it's not the best time oh
it's not your breath underwater what are
you doing done your brain buddy nothing
nothing just kind of shake it up by a
little brush like rusev and meaningless
death why do you do this down he isn't
Rebecca up to the top yeah
um I asked him you know I feel more
erect in that plane that just literally
fell apart on top of us that's a medium
break okay
come on we've really got to get up top
please this is Julia we're coming back
up over it that's not true I'm using I
guess we just got that a whiskey Lowell
and generous
[Music]
wait Julia we gotta decompress here we
we have to decompress
[Music]
I mean you might die hey that's right
stir quickly Oh God
[Music]
it's taking too long this is torture oh
okay there okay what the hell happened
it's cool man everything's all right now
Oh see see I was right to decompress
there was a little mishap with the
barbecue oh Jesus look like the whole
boat was lit up
what's up with that other boat who's
fishing guys came by and ran into the
dive line whatever who cares right what
I want to know is and his money I say is
awesome
we found the plate and it's huge full of
cool stuff unfortunately we did not
leave it as pristine as we could have
what why the dive line actually how bad
there's no cockpit anymore for starters
well that's just [ __ ] perfect I don't
want to piss her off she's an awesome
badass lady
oh hello everything my life stop shaking
these intrepid adventurers then Alex and
his little brother Brad trying to swim
with the big fish both seem out of their
depth and Julia the love of Alex's life
and he the love of hers kid
what about Conrad a bold fellow you
might say well maybe you'd say arrogant
and then there's captain Flitz strong
forthright stubborn she appears somewhat
immune to Conrad's charms yes so far at
least strong independent linear let me
reassure you you help them to make some
decisions they'll value
you're doing well thank you how
well-preserved was his plane pretty much
what you'd expect Brad it was insane it
was like traveling through time no [ __ ]
well it was like traveling through time
and accidentally ending up in a
dimension where the past is underwater
and like everything is covered in
barnacles and sharks sharks it was a
great reef hey I thought it was pretty
intense wasn't comrade gonna get us some
more beers after he helped Flis maybe he
decided hey I'll drink some and then he
got drunk and since he was drunk he
forgot to bring it to us and he just
kept on drinking and he drank all of it
sounds like you've had some experience
with this kind of phenomenon yeah I've
been studying it for you I'll go look
for him oh we found a bullet lodged in
the plane huh I left it below deck if
you want to check it out
ah ah I'll be cheery there a polar bear
you good Toyota fan huh I was just
thinking about how crazy our dive was
can you believe what we just got to
experience
is that no it was pretty unbelievable
something up you can talk to me really I
guess I'm just kind of anxious about
like our future long distance yeah
what's next
nice we often - we've got a long and
happy future together
I do really you know you're pretty much
the best thing that ever happened to me
let's be nice I love you Alex if you
overthink things and ever question it is
you might and little burn in them why
don't you just chill out here so just
enjoy it
hey you see my brother or Flis no I got
distracted let's go get him sure so
which one is you know where the magic
happens
on behalf of my family I'd like to
apologize for my brother acting like a
horny fifth grader it's okay I can deal
with children Conrad beers where are
they
oh yeah the beers I'll just get him now
I love that she's so independent and
fuzzy
I can tell with children
all right now that everybody's here
let's take a look at the navigators pad
we found maybe we can figure out why the
plane was out here where'd you put it
it's in your case okay I'll go get it
okay and no I won't that has been kind
of preoccupied okay
that's been enough for tonight thank you
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this if you want to see more to let me
know in the comment section below
I'm actually really enjoying this it was
very it was kind of confusing at the
beginning because it didn't seem like a
call until dawn asked kind of game where
you have a dynamic you have a group of
characters with their own character arcs
and intertwining relationships that's
kind of what makes it really interesting
but now we're back to that and it
appears that the narrative from the very
start actually does come in two twined
with this one so I'm excited to see
where this goes and struggling just to
do the QuickTime events because as I
explained before I'm playing on a PC but
I'm using my ps4 controller but it's set
up thinking it's an Xbox controller so
if you want to see someone fail all the
quick time then come here do let me know
give this a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
really helps me to know whether you like
these types of videos and have a lovely
day or evening bye